50 ans jour pour
jour après le la guerre déclenchée le
jour de
Kipour nous venons de vivre le 11
septembre de l'État juif cette fois
c'était Chabbat le gen sacré de
simrat la barbarie islamiste a frappé
des femmes des enfants des bébés des
vieillards des familles entières décimé
des femmes violées des corps mutilé film
devant une foule galvanisée par la haine
du Juif le Hamas c'est
daesh des juifs victimes de pogrome 120
années après
kichiniev jamais depuis la tragédie de
la Choa autant de Juifs n'avait été
massacré le même jour mais cette fois
c'est enê Israël quatre Français ont été
tués dans avidane ce magnifique jeune
homme né à Bordeaux quinzaine de disparu
et les 200000 Français d'Israël que j'ai
l'honneur de représenter
sont menacés ou sous les bombes je pense
à eux ne vous y trompez pas cette guerre
est une guerre contre notre civilisation
entre la civilisation et la barbarie non
pas une guerre de territoire les
colonies mais Israël a évacué Gaza
jusqu'au dernier centimètre carré le
Hamas ve un état à la place d'Israël
mais pas à côté d'Israël une nouvelle
fois je veux dire à nos ressortissants
qu'il peuvent compter sur le plein
soutien du gouvern
je lu dis la première chose qui nous
vient à l'esprit c'est l'horreur
l'horreur du terrorisme l'horreur des
témoignages l'horreur face à des hommes
des femmes des enfants massacrés des
hommes des femmes et des enfants enlevés
dont des fillettes de 4 ans le Hamas
groupe terroriste a agi pour terroriser
la population
israélienne face à ces drames nous
sommes au côté Israël et du peuple
israélien Israël a droit à la sécurité
droit de se défendre rien ne peut
excuser le terrorisme enfin Monsieur le
Député vous connaissez mon engagement et
celui de mon gouvernement dans la lutte
contre
l'antisémitisme aucune ambiguïté n'est
possible j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le
dire aucun acte ou propos antisémite
n'est acceptable nous ne les tolérons ni
dans les cortèges ni sur les réseaux
sociaux